This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. Most of us think of moral convictions as a good thing. We have national parks and drunk driving laws because people in the past had moral convictions and acted on them. These threads of moral conviction are deeply sewn into the fabric of our nation, shaping policy and culture across generations. This social security measure gives at least some protection to 30 millions of our citizens who will reap direct benefits through unemployment compensating. General Secretary Gorbachev, if you seek peace,
这里是《隐藏的脑筋》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔。我们大多数人认为道德信念是一件好事。我们有国家公园和酒驾法律，是因为过去的人们心怀道德信念并付诸行动。这些道德信念的线索深深编织进我们国家的肌理，跨越世代塑造着政策与文化。这项社会保障措施至少为三千万通过失业赔偿获得直接利益的公民提供了一些保护。戈尔巴乔夫总书记，如果你寻求和平，
if you seek prosperity for the Soviet Union and Eastern Europe, open this gate, tear down this wall. But new research suggests these moral convictions can be a double-edged sword in the context of a democracy. When we are convinced something is morally correct, it becomes difficult for us to hear views that clash with ours, difficult to have conversations with people who disagree with us, and difficult to make compromises. and difficult to make compromises. This week on Hidden Brain, we bring you the latest in our series featuring counterintuitive ideas
如果你寻求苏联和东欧的繁荣，打开这扇门，拆毁这堵墙。但新的研究表明，在民主的语境下，这些道德信念可能是一把双刃剑。当我们确信某事在道德上是正确的时候，我们就很难听进与我们相左的观点，很难与意见不合的人进行对话，也很难做出妥协。也很难做出妥协。本周的《隐藏的脑筋》节目中，我们将为您带来系列节目的最新内容，探讨反直觉的理念
about the state of the world in 2020. As an election campaign rages around us, we ask, can our moral convictions keep us from actually achieving our moral convictions. There are many things about this year's US presidential election that feel unprecedented, but this pandemic year campaign is also part of a long through-line of hotly contested
关于2020年世界的状态。随着选举竞选在我们周围如火如荼地展开，我们不禁要问，我们的道德信念是否会阻碍我们真正实现我们的道德信念。今年美国总统大选有许多感觉空前绝后的方面，但这场大流行之年的竞选也是长期以来激烈角逐的一脉相承
political struggles. There have been many times in recent decades where people have felt that the stakes of a political or policy battle were high and that the outcome could affect our nation's trajectory in profound ways. Researchers have tried to understand how American voters come to their views on contentious issues. They find that many Americans seem to see political questions not just in terms of policy, but as a test of their moral principles. In other words, we're not just talking about the environment or immigration or guns. We're debating right from wrong. environment or immigration or guns. We're debating right from wrong. Psychologist Linda Skitka has studied the effects of moral conviction in politics and its effects on democracy. Linda Skitka, welcome to Hidden Brain.
政治斗争的一部分。在过去的几十年里，有许多时刻，人们觉得一场政治或政策斗争的利害关系重大，其结果可能会对我们国家的轨迹产生深远的影响。研究人员试图了解美国选民是如何对有争议的问题形成看法的。他们发现，许多美国人看待政治问题时，不仅仅是从政策角度出发，而是将其视为对自身道德原则的考验。换句话说，我们谈论的不只是环境、移民或枪支。我们在辩论正义与邪恶。环境、移民或枪支。我们在辩论正义与邪恶。心理学家琳达·斯基特卡（Linda Skitka）研究了道德信念在政治中的影响及其对民主的影响。琳达·斯基特卡，欢迎来到《隐藏的脑筋》。
Thank you. I'm happy to be here. What are some issues today, Linda, where you think people have more than just strong views where they actually have very strong moral convictions? What are some issues today Linda where you think people have more than just strong views where they actually have very strong moral convictions? People can have moral convictions about almost anything but some issues on average are higher and more conviction than others. Things like same-sex marriage, immigration, It's all feeling debatable being children deserve a mom and a dad. Say it down, say it, Glenn! Immigrants, I'll walk up here! Say it down, say it!
谢谢你。很高兴来到这里。琳达，在今天的一些问题上，你认为人们不仅仅是有强烈的观点，而是真正拥有非常强烈的道德信念，这些问题有哪些呢？琳达，在今天的一些问题上，你认为人们不仅仅是有强烈的观点，而是真正拥有非常强烈的道德信念，这些问题有哪些呢？人们对几乎任何事情都可以有道德信念，但平均而言，某些问题上的道德信念比其他问题更高。比如同性恋婚姻、移民，这一切都感觉充满争议，孩子们理应拥有一个妈妈和一个爸爸。说出来，说出来，格伦！移民，我走上来！说出来，说出来！
It's a really debatable thing. Children deserve a mom and a dad. It's only right. That's just the way it is. You can't change nature. I firmly believe in equal rights for all people. It's as simple as that. Gun control, police violence, all host of issues.
这是一个极具争议的话题。孩子们理应拥有一个妈妈和一个爸爸。这是理所当然的。事实就是如此。你无法改变大自然。我坚信所有人享有平等权利。就这么简单。枪支管制、警察暴力，以及一系列其他问题。
I don't want the government taking my rights, my liberty, my God, give it right to protect myself. They say that tougher gun laws do not decrease gun violence. We call B.S! They say a good guy with a gun stops a bad guy with a gun. We call B.S! Black Lives Matter! Black Lives Matter!
我不希望政府剥夺我的权利、我的自由、我的上帝赋予我保护自己的权利。他们说更严厉的枪支法不会减少枪支暴力。我们认为是胡扯！他们说一个带枪的好人能阻止一个带枪的坏人。我们认为是胡扯！黑人的命也是命！黑人的命也是命！
Blue Lives Matter! Blue Lives Matter! Black men, Black men, Black men, Black men, Black men, Black men, Black men, Black men. Now on the surface having strong policy views about something and having moral convictions about something can superficially seem similar, but you and others have identified several hallmarks of moral conviction. I think of these almost like a litmus test. When you see one or more of these, it's a clue that you're dealing not just with policy disagreements, but something deeper. In one of your studies, you looked at people's reactions to this Supreme Court judgment.
警察的命也是命！警察的命也是命！黑人，黑人，黑人，黑人，黑人，黑人，黑人，黑人。表面上看，对某事持有强烈的政策观点和对某事持有道德信念，表面上似乎很相似，但你和其他人已经识别出了道德信念的几个标志。我几乎把这些看作是一种试金石。当你看到其中一个或多个时，这就成了一个线索：你面对的不仅仅是政策分歧，而是更深层次的东西。在你的其中一项研究中，你观察了人们对最高法院这项判决的反应。
Take a listen to this piece of tape. Today, the Supreme Court upheld Oregon's law permitting physician-assisted suicide. The six to three rulings said that the Bush administration had, in effect, criminalized the practice without the authorization of Congress. Linda, what was this case about? The case was about Oregon's death with Dignity Act. Oregon had legalized physician-assisted suicide some years ago. The Bush administration challenged it on the grounds that it violated the Federal Control
听听这段录音。今天，最高法院维持了俄勒冈州允许医生协助自杀的法律。六比三的裁决称，布什政府在未经国会授权的情况下，实际上将这种做法定为刑事犯罪。琳达，这个案件是关于什么的？这个案件涉及俄勒冈州的《尊严死法案》。俄勒冈州几年前将医生协助自杀合法化。布什政府对其提出挑战，理由是它违反了联邦管制
Substance Act. And, of course, the question of whether people have the right to end their lives, presumably that's something that would elicit very strong moral convictions. At the time that the court heard the case about 50% of Americans were completely against it and 50% of Americans were supportive of it. So when you conducted a study in it, you asked volunteers about their views about the verdict, walk me through what you did and what you found. We contacted a nationally representative sample of adults in the United States,
物质法。当然，关于人们是否有权结束自己生命的问，这大概会激起非常强烈的道德信念。在法院审理此案时，大约50%的美国人完全反对，50%的美国人支持。因此，当你对此进行研究时，你询问了志愿者对这一裁决的看法，请带我了解一下你做了什么以及你发现了什么。我们联系了美国全国具有代表性的成年人样本，
and after the court calendar was announced, but before the Supreme Court heard arguments in the case, we surveyed these people and asked them to what degree their feelings about physician-assisted suicide were moral convictions, the degree to which they were experienced as religious convictions, as well as their standing perceptions of the Supreme Court, on the degree to which they've perceived the court as legitimate, trustworthy, and procedurally fair. What Linda and her colleagues were trying to tease out was the effect that moral convictions might have on people's views about Supreme Court decisions. Would people with strong moral convictions see the court decisions as more legitimate or less?
在法院日程公布之后、最高法院审理此案的辩论之前，我们对这些人进行了调查，询问他们对医生协助自杀的感受在多大程度上属于道德信念，在多大程度上被体验为宗教信念，以及他们对最高法院的既有看法，即他们认为法院具有合法性、值得信赖和程序公正的程度。琳达和她的同事们试图探究的是，道德信念可能对人们关于最高法院裁决的看法产生的影响。持有强烈道德信念的人会认为法院的裁决更有合法性还是更少？
After doing this initial survey, they waited for the Supreme Court ruling to come down. The High Court refused to hear the challenges to Oregon's law. That was effectively a legal go-ahead for the state to try its right to die law. And then we contacted the exact same people again to find out what predicted their perceptions that the Supreme Court decision was an outcome that was fair and that it was a decision that they would accept as binding,
在做了这项初步调查后，他们等待最高法院裁决的下达。最高法院拒绝审理对俄勒冈州法律的挑战。这实际上是为该州尝试其实施安乐死法律亮起了法律绿灯。然后我们再次联系了这同一群人，以了解是什么预测了他们的看法，即最高法院的决定是一个公平的结果，并且这是一个他们会接受为具有约束力的决定，
as well as their subsequent perceptions of trust, procedural fairness, and legitimacy of the court. Linda found that lots of people accepted the ruling of the Supreme Court, even if they disagreed with it. Lots of people accept those with strong moral convictions. They saw the Supreme Court as more legitimate, more trustworthy, and more procedurally fair if they agreed with the decision, and saw the Supreme Court as less trustworthy, less procedurally fair and
以及他们随后对法院的信任度、程序公正性和合法性的看法。琳达发现，很多人接受了最高法院的裁决，即使他们不同意。很多人接受那些拥有强烈道德信念的人。如果他们同意这一决定，他们就会认为最高法院更具合法性、更值得信赖且程序更公正；如果他们不同意，则认为最高法院更不值得信赖、程序更不公正，且
less legitimate if they disagreed with it. So this seems to be one of the defining hallmarks of moral convictions. And in some ways when we hear an authority figure come down on something, our reaction is not to say, is it possible there was something wrong with my moral conviction? Our reaction is to say, is there something wrong with the institution? Are there other examples like this, Linda, in public life? Several examples of this.
合法性更低。因此，这似乎是道德信念的决定性标志之一。在某种程度上，当我们听到权威人士对某事做出裁决时，我们的反应不是说：“我的道德信念可能有什么不对劲吗？”我们的反应是说：“这个机构有什么不对劲吗？”琳达，公众生活中还有其他这样的例子吗？这样的例子有好几个。
We have found the exact same pattern of results when looking at pre-imposed reactions to the US Supreme Court's decision in a variety of the same sex marriage decisions that were made in the recent years. We see it in reaction to lower court decisions as well. For example, turned out that participants thought vigilante justice was equally fair
当我们观察美国最高法院近年来做出的一系列同性恋婚姻裁决的前后反应时，我们发现了完全相同的模式。我们在对下级法院裁决的反应中也看到了这一点。例如，事实证明，如果参与者在道德上确信被告是有罪的，他们会认为私刑正义同样公平，
if they had a moral conviction that a defendant was guilty, for example, as a court decision to use the death penalty. And we find this again and again, that when people have morally convicted policy preferences, they don't care how those policy preferences or outcomes are achieved. They just care that they are achieved. And so if it takes lying or cheating to achieve that outcome, that's fine.
例如，就像法院判处死刑的决定一样。我们一次又一次地发现，当人们对政策偏好抱有道德信念时，他们并不关心这些政策偏好或结果是如何实现的。他们只关心它们是否实现了。因此，如果实现这一结果需要说谎或作弊，那也没关系。
Huh, I'm thinking how this plays out even on a national scale. You see this in all kinds of different ways. When former president Barack Obama nominatedama nominated mary garland to the u.s. supreme court for instance the senate basically said we can take up this nomination because there's a presidential election under way this year the american people should have a say in who this next supreme court justice is
嗯，我在想这在国家层面上是如何体现的。你在各种不同的方面都能看到这一点。例如，当美国前总统巴拉克·奥巴马提名梅里克·加兰进入美国参议院时，参议院基本上表示，我们不能审议这项提名，因为今年正值总统大选，美国人民应该对下一任最高法院大法官是谁拥有发言权
senate majority leader michael mcconald made the argument that an election year was not a good time to consider a Supreme Court justice. The next justice could fundamentally alter the direction of the Supreme Court and have a profound impact on our country. So of course, of course, the American people should have a say in the Court's direction. And of course, McConnell's views from 2015 have come up repeatedly in recent weeks
参议院多数党领袖米奇·麦康奈尔提出论点，认为选举年不是审议最高法院大法官的好时机。下一任大法官可能会从根本上改变最高法院的方向，并对我们国家产生深远的影响。所以，当然，美国人民理所当然应该对法院的方向拥有发言权。当然，麦康奈尔在2015年的观点在最近几周被多次提及，
as Republicans are racing to push through a Senate vote on the seat held by Ruth Badeginsburg. Today it is my honor to nominate one of our nation's most brilliant and gifted legal minds to the Supreme Court, Judge Amy Coney Barrett. legal minds to the supreme court judge amie kony barren there was clear precedent behind the predictable outcome that came out of
因为共和党人正竞相推动参议院对由鲁斯·巴德·金斯伯格占据的席位进行投票。今天，我很荣幸地提名我国最杰出、最有天赋的法律界精英之一进入最高法院，她就是艾米·康尼·巴雷特法官。法律界精英之一进入最高法院，她就是艾米·康尼·巴雷特法官。2016年所产生的好预测结果背后有清晰的先例，
twenty sixteen and there's even more overwhelming precedent behind the fact that this senate will vote on this nomination this year and so again what what it suggests is you know the friday from the point of your democrats you might sort of say much mcconald is a bad person leader mcconald is basically decided the rules don't apply to republicans even their own rules it's just broot political force
而参议院今年将对这一提名进行投票的事实背后，更是有着压倒性的先例。所以再次说明，从民主党人的角度来看，你可能会说麦康奈尔是个糟糕的人，领袖麦康奈尔基本上决定了规则对共和党人不适用，甚至他们自己的规则也不适用，这简直就是赤裸裸的政治力量
but perhaps the better way to think about it is a mitch mcconald has such strong moral convictions about who should be on the supreme court that how that happens the means in some ways are less important than the ends, that the ends justify the means. Exactly, that's a great example. I'm wondering, Linda, when you look at these two examples, you know, the distrust of authority that we sometimes see and the tendency towards vigilante justice, do you think the speaks at all to a phenomenon that other people have commented on, which is that in the last 20 or 30 years, there's been a decline in trust in institutions writ large in the country.
但也许更好的思考方式是，米奇·麦康奈尔对于谁应该进入最高法院有着如此强烈的道德信念，以至于事情是如何发生的——手段在某种程度上不如目的重要，即目的可以为手段辩护。没错，这是一个极好的例子。琳达，我想知道，当你审视这两个例子时，你知道，我们有时看到的对权威的不信任以及对私刑正义的倾向，你认为这能在多大程度上说明其他人评论过的一个现象，即在过去20或30年里，人们对国家大大小小机构的信任度一直在下降。
There's been a decline in trust in Congress, in the presidency, in courts, in the media, in schools, in academia, and universities. Across the board, there's generally been a decline in trust, in institutions, in authority, and expertise. Do you think the two things are related? I think they well could be. That we're a period of intense polarization, where although actually the policy concerns of most Democrats and Republicans overlap,
人们对国会、总统、法院、媒体、学校、学术界和大学的信任度都在下降。总的来说，对机构、权威和专业知识的信任普遍在下降。你认为这两者是有联系的？我认为很可能是。我们正处于一个极端两极分化的时期，尽管事实上大多数民主党人和共和党人的政策关切重叠，
their distaste of each other is extreme, and they don't believe that they have common concerns anymore. And this is a ripe environment for people to start seeing things on their side and on other sides is objectively wrong. When we are morally convinced about something, we don't usually need evidence to support our conclusions. We know how we feel. We can feel it. This might be one reason an increase in the intensity of our moral convictions might be linked to a decrease in our interest in scientific evidence. It's also linked to a disregard for experts.
但他们对彼此的厌恶是极端的，他们不再相信彼此有共同的关切。这是一个肥沃的土壤，让人开始认为自己这一方和对方的一方是客观错误的。当我们对某事深信不疑时，我们通常不需要证据来支持我们的结论。我们知道自己的感受。我们能感受到。这可能是我们的道德信念强度增加与我们对科学证据兴趣减少相关的一个原因。这也与对专家的蔑视有关。
A scientist might tell you something important about a topic you know nothing about. Why do you need her expertise when it comes to something where you feel like an expert yourself? When people have a really strong moral conviction, the moral convictions have two characteristics. People believe their conviction is objectively correct and as objectively correct is the fact about the world. So if I'm pro-life on abortion, I see the idea is abortion as being wrong, as equally obvious as 2 plus 2 equals 4. Okay, and so given that I know the 2 plus 2 equals 4, or that abortion is wrong, I don't need an authority to explain it to me.
一位科学家可能会告诉你一些关于你一无所知的领域的重要事情。当涉及到你觉得自己本身就像个专家的领域时，你为什么还需要她的专业知识呢？当人们有非常强烈的道德信念时，道德信念有两个特征。人们相信他们的信念是客观正确的，并且像关于世界的事实一样客观正确。因此，如果我在堕胎问题上反堕胎，我认为堕胎是错误的这一观点，其显而易见程度就如同2加2等于4。好的，鉴于我知道2加2等于4，或者说堕胎是错误的，我不需要权威来向我解释。
And in fact, if the authority does try to explain it to me in a different light, I'm going to start to question the authority because can't they see, quote, what the obvious facts are on the ground? But remember, this is a psychological perception. I am perceiving this to be fact-like when it's really a matter of my subjective state of mind and when I'm attaching moral significance to. Mm-hmm.
事实上，如果权威确实试图以不同的角度向我解释，我就会开始质疑权威，因为难道他们看不到实地上所谓的明显事实是什么吗？但请记住，这是一种心理感知。当我把它当作事实一样来感知时，实际上这只是我主观心智状态的问题，是我附加了道德意义的问题。嗯。
And I feel like I can see examples of this all the time, you know, Dr. Anthony Fauci, who has been involved in briefing the country on coronavirus, you know, has sometimes been criticized by supporters of President Donald Trump as being an agent of the deep state. And in some ways, I feel like that's the same idea, right? His expertise is being questioned because his expertise is challenging people's moral convictions about what's right and what's wrong. I think that's exactly the case.
我觉得我能一直看到这样的例子，你知道，安东尼·福奇博士一直参与向全国简报冠状病毒的情况，你知道，有时被总统唐纳德·特朗普的支持者批评为深层政府的代理人。在某种程度上，我觉得这是同一个想法，对吧？他的专业知识受到质疑，是因为他的专业知识挑战了人们对什么是对、什么是错的道德信念。我认为情况正是如此。
And we've seen it repeatedly in research where people do question and distrust authorities to get it right when they have moral convictions, strong moral convictions about outcomes. Another example of that was asking people before a Supreme Court decision whether they trusted the Supreme Court to get the decision right, even before the Supreme Court heard anything in the case. If you have strong moral convictions about the issue, you not only rated that you just trusted the court to get it right, you did it very fast and automatically. You would give that response much more quickly than somebody who didn't have a moral conviction about the case. So it's interesting. We're not looking at authority figures or experts in order to inform us, we're almost evaluating
我们在研究中一再看到这一点，当人们对结果抱有强烈的道德信念时，他们确实会质疑并怀疑权威能否做到正确。其中的另一个例子是，在最高法院做出裁决之前，询问人们是否信任最高法院能做出正确的决定，甚至在最高法院审理此案的任何内容之前。如果你对这个问题有强烈的道德信念，你不仅会评价你信任法院能做出正确决定，而且你会非常迅速且自动地做出这一反应。与对案件没有道德信念的人相比，你会更快地给出这种反应。所以这很有趣。我们不是为了获得信息而去看权威人士或专家，我们几乎是在评估
them to say, do they measure up or match our moral convictions? Correct. Again, there's many other occasions where we don't have moral convictions and we're going to have to use expertise and aspects of procedural fairness as a proxy, but when we do have moral convictions, that all goes out the window. You mentioned this a moment ago, but I think it's worth dwelling on for a second, where you said that people's moral convictions feel like saying 2 plus 2 equals 4. Talk about this idea that moral convictions have this intuitive power that makes them feel as if, of course, they must be true, they're self-evidently true.
他们，看看他们是否符合或匹配我们的道德信念？没错。同样，在许多其他情况下，我们没有道德信念，我们将不得不使用专业知识和程序公正的某些方面作为替代指标，但当我们确实拥有道德信念时，这一切都烟消云散了。你刚才提到了这一点，但我认为值得深入探讨一下，你曾说过，人们的道德信念感觉就像说2加2等于4。谈谈这种观点，即道德信念具有这种直觉力量，让人觉得它们理所当然必须是真的，它们是不言而喻的真理。
Most of us probably share a moral conviction that murder is wrong, and now imagine that somebody challenges you and says, you know what? Murder's not really wrong. You probably look at them and like, are you nuts? It's so obvious. Yeah. Of course, murder's wrong.
我们大多数人可能都有这样一种道德信念：谋杀是错误的，现在想象一下，如果有人挑战你并说，你知道吗？谋杀其实并不是错的。你可能会看着他们，心想：你疯了吗？这太明显了。是的。当然，谋杀是错的。
And that's why people experience their moral convictions about other issues as well. You know, not everyone may have a moral conviction about abortion or gun control, for example. And people who don't have moral convictions about them are more likely to be open to argument, to trust procedures to get the issue right, but when you do have moral conviction about them, it's just so obvious to you that the only correct outcome is your position that any
这就是为什么人们对其他问题的道德信念也有同样的体验。你知道，并不是每个人都对堕胎或枪支管制等问题抱有道德信念。那些对这些问题没有道德信念的人更有可能对论点持开放态度，相信程序能够正确处理问题，但是当你对它们抱有道德信念时，这对手头的事来说太显而易见了，以至于唯一的正确结果就是你的立场，任何
procedure or court case or anything else like that that doesn't yield it has to be wrong. Moral convictions involves subjective states of mind. We all recognize this, we understand, this is why you can be morally offended by something that I find unobjectionable and that I can be offended by something that you think is just fine. But the paradox is that when we are in the grip of moral conviction,
未能产生这一结果的程序、法庭案件或任何类似的事情都必定是错误的。道德信念涉及主观的心智状态。我们都认识到这一点，我们理解，这就是为什么你可能会被我认为无可厚非的事情在道德上冒犯，而我也可能会被你认为完全没问题的事情所冒犯。但矛盾的是，当我们受制于道德信念时，
we forget that we are experiencing something subjective. Our convictions feel objectively true, like saying 2 plus 2 equals 4. This is an illusion, but it's a powerful one, and it leads us to a powerful conclusion. I feel that what I experience is morally correct cannot just be true for me. It has to be true for you.
我们忘记了我们正在体验某种主观的东西。我们的信念感觉是客观真实的，就像说2加2等于4一样。这是一种错觉，但它是一种强大的错觉，它引导我们得出一个强有力的结论。我觉得我在道德上认为是正确的东西，不可能仅仅对我是正确的。它对你也必须是正确的。
I think one aspect of it is that people psychologically experience their moral convictions, just like the table in front of you is an objective reality. We believe that our moral convictions have that same quality. That anybody looking at the table should recognize as a table, anybody looking at your moral conviction should recognize that as a moral conviction. So we think that these are real,
我认为其中的一个方面是，人们在心理上体验他们的道德信念，就像你面前的桌子是一个客观现实一样。我们相信我们的道德信念也具有同样的品质。任何看着这张桌子的人都应该把它认作是一张桌子，任何看着你的道德信念的人都应该把它认作是一种道德信念。所以我们认为这些是真实的、
objectively true features of the world. And that may be related to our sense of needing to believe ourselves as being moral ourselves and that we're good. And so we draw lines in the sand in order to convince ourselves that we're actually a people of moral character. And therefore we really cling to these because to attack them is also to attack us as moral agents. You know another example would be as wrong for anybody to enter the United States illegally. We are the entire of people this respecting coming over by the thousand. And they just want to destroy this country.
世界上客观真实的特征。这可能与我们需要让自己相信自己是有道德的、我们是好人的这种感觉有关。因此，我们在沙滩上划定界限，以此来说服自己，我们实际上是具有道德品质的人。因此，我们真的紧紧抓住这些不放，因为攻击它们也就是在攻击我们作为道德主体的身份。你知道，另一个例子是，任何人非法进入美国都是错误的。我们是一个尊重合法入境却成千上万涌入的国家。他们只想毁了这个国家。
And the fact of matters is that God gives you something whether it's a family or a country. You're supposed to take care of it. That's your responsibility. To the extent that you have that position, taking any steps to protect against it would seem reasonable. And some people have a moral conviction that there should be legal routes to immigration, particularly for people who have already been in the United States for a long time in paying taxes. I want my family together!
事实是，上帝赐予你一些东西，无论是家庭还是国家。你应该照顾好它。那是你的责任。在你有这种立场的范围内，采取任何步骤来防范它似乎都是合理的。有些人则有一种道德信念，认为应该有合法的移民途径，特别是对于那些已经在美国呆了很长时间并纳税的人来说。我要我的家人团聚！
I want my family together! For them, blocking that and deporting people who have lived in the United States for 20 years is just objectively wrong. So obviously objectively wrong to them, that again making arguments about it seems to be, again, just saying, okay, murder is fine. And I think people are willing to have one conversation about this with people who disagree with them, because they understand the facts of what's right or wrong about this issue, that surely they will get the other person to agree with them about it. It's when that actually we can't get other people to agree with us about that one thing.
我要我的家人团聚！对他们来说，阻止这一点并驱逐在美国生活了20年的人简直是客观上大错特错。这在他们看来是如此明显地客观错误，以至于再次就此进行争论似乎就像是在说“好吧，谋杀是可以的”。我认为人们愿意与不同意他们观点的人就此进行一次对话，因为他们了解这个问题的对错事实，他们确信自己一定能说服对方同意他们的看法。正是当实际上我们无法让其他人就那一件事与我们达成一致时，
Then we almost have to hate them because to not agree with you about that must mean that they're evil, especially after you've revealed to them and explained to them why you believe what you believe. Linda Skitka has an example from her own life about how moral convictions work, the intense emotions that accompany them, the disinterest in evidence, the distrust of authority figures who might challenge them. That's when we come back. Psychologist Linda Skitka studies something most of us take for granted. The moral convictions that often animate national debates. We've looked at how moral convictions cause us to disregard the opinions of experts to
然后我们几乎不得不憎恨他们，因为在向他们展示并解释了你为什么相信你所相信的之后，不同意你的看法一定意味着他们是邪恶的。琳达·斯基特卡有一个来自她自身生活的例子，关于道德信念是如何运作的、伴随它们的强烈情绪、对证据的漠不关心，以及对可能挑战它们的权威人士的不信任。这就是我们归来时要谈的。心理学家琳达·斯基特卡研究了我们大多数人认为理所当然的事情。经常推动全国辩论的道德信念。我们已经探讨了道德信念如何导致我们忽视专家的意见、
question authority. When a court's conclusions line up with our moral convictions, we call the process fair. When they don't, we say the system is rigged. Another hallmark of moral convictions that Linda and others have identified has to do with the idea that we believe our moral convictions are true, not just for us and our circumstances, but for everyone, everywhere, maybe even at all times. We tend to believe that our moral convictions are universally true, so if we decide X is morally wrong, then X was morally wrong
质疑权威。当法院的结论符合我们的道德信念时，我们称这个过程是公正的。当它们不符合时，我们就说这个系统是被操纵的。琳达和其他人发现的道德信念的另一个标志与这样一个观念有关：我们相信我们的道德信念是正确的，不仅对我们和我们的处境如此，而且对每个人、每个地方、甚至可能在所有时候都如此。我们倾向于认为我们的道德信念是普遍正确的，所以如果我们认定X在道德上是错误的，那么X在
50 or 100 years ago as well, and if X is morally wrong, for example, for those of us in the US, it's not only wrong in the US, it's wrong in other countries as well. Linda has an example of this that many listeners may find deeply unsettling. The subject of female genital cutting. There are many countries in the world where female genital cutting is a cultural norm that lesseners are very often haven't heard of this practice and when they do tend to react very emotionally and morally object to it. And so Western feminists, for example, have no problem saying that female circumcision
50年前或100年前也是错误的，如果X在道德上是错误的，例如对于我们这些在美国的人来说，它不仅在美国是错的，在其他国家也是错的。琳达有一个关于此的例子，许多听众可能会觉得极其不安。女性外阴切除术的主题。世界上有许多国家，女性外阴切除术是一种文化规范，听众往往没有听说过这种做法，当他们听说时，往往会做出非常情绪化的反应，并在道德上反对它。因此，例如，西方女权主义者毫不犹豫地表示，女性割礼
should be banned in countries they've never visited, with women they've never spoken to, no examination of what the cultural meaning of the practice might be for the people who practice it, or consideration that maybe as normative to them is male circumcision is to us. They are very quick and willing to say, no, this should be wrong not only for us in the United States, but for women everywhere. Linda had a similarly strong reaction herself when she first heard about the issue many years ago. But she did something that most of us don't do. She examined her own reaction with curiosity.
应该在她们从未访问过的国家、与她们从未交谈过的女性中被禁止，而没有调查这种做法对实践它的人来说可能具有什么文化意义，也没有考虑这或许对她们而言就像男性割礼对我们而言一样是规范的。她们非常迅速且愿意说，不，这不仅对我们美国人来说是错的，对世界各地的女性来说也应该是错的。多年前琳达第一次听到这个问题时，她自己也有同样强烈的反应。但她做了一件我们大多数人不会做的事。她带着好奇心审视了自己的反应。
Now, if you want me to jump ahead at the story, I can tell you that Linda still has deep moral concerns about female genital cutting. But she also feels her journey on this issue reveals a great deal about how moral convictions work. I first learned about that something like female circumcision even existed in women's studies classes I took in college some 30 years ago and was pretty horrified that this
现在，如果你想让我跳到故事的后面，我可以告诉你，琳达对女性外阴切除术依然有着深深的道德关切。但她也觉得她在这一问题上的心路历程揭示了大量关于道德信念如何运作的道理。大约30年前，我在大学修读妇女研究课程时，第一次了解到女性割礼这样的事情甚至存在，并且对这
was a possibility. It was described as a heinous practice. It was also described in terms of female genital mutilation. It wasn't described as circumcision. So mutilation by definition is going to conjure up a lot more aggressive act than female circumcision might. It was emphasized that sometimes these practices happened in very unsteerial situations and sometimes with non-surgical tools such as with glass. So the description certainly was horrifying and I think was intended to moralize the topic.
是一种可能性感到相当惊恐。它被描述为一种惨绝人寰的做法。它也是在女性生殖器切割的术语下被描述的。它不被称为割礼。因此，按定义，切割会比女性割礼更能勾起人们好斗的举动。其中强调，有时这些做法发生在非常不无菌的情况下，有时甚至使用非手术工具，例如玻璃。所以这种描述当然是令人恐怖的，我认为这是意在将这个话题道德化。
And describe for me when you're sitting in that class, if you still recall it, what the emotion was that went through you when you heard about it. Oh gosh, a flood of adrenaline. This is a very intense visual reaction. And that wasn't until years later that that occurred to me as like, wow, that was my first really self-aware moral conviction. Linda realized this when she stumbled on an article about the topic.
请向我描述一下，当你坐在那个课堂上时，如果你还记得的话，当你听到这件事时，内心经历了什么情绪？哦天哪，一股肾上腺素涌上心头。这是一种非常强烈的视觉反应。直到多年后，我才意识到这一点，心想：“哇，那是我第一次真正有自我意识的道德信念。”当琳达偶然读到一篇关于这个话题的文章时，她意识到了这一点。
She realized she had reached her conclusions without needing much by way of evidence. The strength of her feeling was evidence enough that what she was feeling had to be true. And it was also because I was exposed to the work of Richard Schroeder who had written a review piece, the medical literature and survey research on female circumcision that really challenged all my beliefs, that in surveys of women who have experienced the procedure, many of them laugh at the idea that Western feminists are concerned about it. Laugh at the idea that they might experience any diminished sexual pleasure.
她意识到，自己得出结论时并没有借助于太多的证据。她内心的强烈感受本身就是足够的证据，证明她所感受到的必定是真实存在的。这也是因为我接触到了理查德·施罗德（Richard Schroeder）的作品，他写了一篇评论文章，探讨了关于女性割礼的医学文献和调查研究，这真的挑战了我所有的信念。在对经历过这一程序的女性的调查中，许多人对西方女权主义者的担忧付诸一笑。嘲笑她们可能会经历任何性快感减弱的想法。
His review also includes medical research that shows the extent of damage or any medical indications of problems with, say, sexual functioning or other problems that suggested those problems were minor to nonexistent. So this whole chapter was reviewing evidence to challenge my initial belief that this was morally wrong. I'm wondering if this is following from the idea that we talked about earlier that our moral convictions don't just seem to be our moral convictions.
他的综述还包括医学研究，这些研究显示了损伤的程度或性功能障碍等问题出现医学征兆的范围，并表明这些问题是微不足道的或根本不存在的。所以整章都在回顾证据，以挑战我最初认为这在道德上是错误的信念。我想知道这是否源于我们之前讨论过的观点，即我们的道德信念似乎不仅仅是我们的道德信念。
They just seem to be truths that we adhere to, that everyone else should also adhere to. Then in other words, they are universal because they're self-evidently true. Exactly. It's going back to that two plus two equals four part because it is so self-evidently true. We don't need to ask the women for example and other cultures whether they they value a given cultural practice. So we already know the right answer and are sure that they are bound to agree with us. And again from a psychological perspective,
它们似乎只是我们坚持的真理，其他人也应该坚持。换句话说，它们是普遍的，因为它们是不言而喻的真理。完全正确。这又回到了“2加2等于4”的那一部分，因为它太不言而喻了。例如，我们不需要询问其他文化中的女性，她们是否珍视某项特定的文化实践。所以我们已经知道了正确的答案，并且确信她们必然会同意我们的看法。同样，从心理学的角度来看，
you're sort of looking at your own mind now, and you're saying, I had a strong moral conviction about this, and I've read this review article, and it's shaking my moral conviction a little bit. What did that tell you? I mean, I think most people are caught up in the question of, is this a right thing to do, or is this a wrong thing to do? And of course, that's an important question to discuss.
你现在有点在审视你自己的内心，你在说：“我对这件事抱有强烈的道德信念，我读了这篇综述文章，它稍微动摇了我的道德信念。”这告诉你什么？我的意思是，我想大多数人都纠结于这个问题：这是一件正确的事情，还是一件错误的事情？当然，这是一个需要讨论的重要问题。
But from a psychological point of view, what you are getting at in some ways is you are gleaning some insights into how your own mind was working. What were those insights? Most of all that I had not done any independent research to back up my initial moral conviction on the topic. So I basically realized I was really uninformed when instead
但从心理学的角度来看，你在某种程度上所探究的是，你正在对自己的心智是如何运作的获得一些洞察。那些洞察是什么？最重要的是，我没有做任何独立的调查研究来支持我最初在这个话题上的道德信念。所以我基本上意识到自己其实非常无知，而
it felt like I knew everything that was to know. And that the psychology of that feeling, I already knew everything I need to know was interesting, because it was really based, I think, more on a strong emotional reaction than anything really based on facts. So at this point, you hadn't yet sort of started the research agenda, but one of the things you would eventually find, of course, is that research agenda, but one of the things you would eventually find, of course, is that more convictions often have this quality to them, that we know that their things are right or things are wrong without necessarily having the evidence for it, that the evidence in some ways follows our convictions. It doesn't proceed it. Yes. And what we know about people is that we tend to seek out information that confirms
与此同时我却觉得自己无所不知。那种“我已知晓所需一切”的感觉背后的心理学很有趣，因为它其实更多地是基于强烈的感情用事，而不是真正基于事实。所以在这个时候，你还没有开始研究议程，但你最终会发现的一件事是，当然，道德信念通常具有这样的品质：我们知道事情是对的还是错的，而不一定有证据支持，证据在某种程度上跟随我们的信念。它并不在前面。是的。我们对人们的了解是，我们倾向于寻找证实
our beliefs more than we seek out information that will disconfirm them. And so, likely once the moral conviction is developed, you're going to be showing that same bias. You're going to be collecting information that's going to support that initial moral conviction that rather than challenge it. Which was true in my case. I only came across these counterarguments completely by accident. What's interesting here from a psychological point of view is how it is become to our conclusion.
我们的信念的信息，而不是寻找会证伪它们的信息。因此，很可能一旦道德信念形成，你就会表现出同样的偏见。你会收集那些支持你最初的道德信念的信息，而不是挑战它的信息。我的情况正是如此。我完全是偶然遇到这些反论的。从心理学的角度来看，这里有趣的是我们是如何得出结论的。
So in some ways when you're raising this issue, my first reaction is why is Linda talking about this issue? I don't understand. This seems bizarre. This seems wrong to even be discussing this question. And that reaction, the reaction that I have, that even discussing the issue is problematic, in some ways is testament to how moral convictions work. Exactly. Talking about this topic, like right now talking about it and knowing that an audience might hear all of this, is worrisome. Because I know that it arouses really strong reactions in people,
所以在某种程度上，当你提出这个问题时，我的第一反应是：琳达为什么要谈论这个话题？我不明白。这显得很离奇。甚至讨论这个问题似乎都是错误的。而这种反应——我所拥有的反应，即甚至讨论这个问题都是有问题的——在某种程度上证明了道德信念是如何运作的。完全正确。谈论这个话题，就像现在这样谈论它，并且知道观众可能会听到这一切，是令人担忧的。因为我知道这会激起人们非常强烈的反应，
but that's part of the psychology that I'm really interested in studying. That kind of depth of really strong reactions. and people, but that's part of the psychology that I'm really interested in studying. That kind of depth of really strong reactions. Independent of what's right or wrong, that psychological reaction is fascinating. So it's a great demonstration of what it means to have a moral conviction. It makes people very uncomfortable to bring it up. And that's probably a natural reaction to even perhaps attack me. It's like, are you suggesting it could ever possibly be right?
但这是我真正有兴趣研究的心理学的一部分。那种真正强烈反应的深度。和人们的反应，但这正是我真正有兴趣研究的心理学的一部分。那种真正强烈反应的深度。抛开对错不论，这种心理反应是迷人的。所以这是一个极好的例证，说明了拥有道德信念意味着什么。提出这个话题会让人们感到非常不舒服。这可能也是一种自然的反应，甚至可能是攻击我。就像是在说：“你是在暗示这可能永远是正确的吗？”
That's part of the psychology of moral conviction. And what do you think it is that basically when someone even asks the question, you know, should we actually be looking at this, how did this come about? I'm looking at this with curiosity. When it comes to our moral convictions, curiosity itself is sort of indicative of guilt in a way, right? In other words, if I'm basically I'm curious about why the Nazis did something, that almost makes me suspect in a way because you're sort of saying, well, why are you so interested in trying to figure out what the mechanisms of this isn't as obviously wrong?
这是道德信念心理学的一部分。当你甚至提出这个问题时——你知道，我们真的应该看看这个吗？这是怎么产生的？——你认为这是什么？我是带着好奇心来看待这一点的。当谈到我们的道德信念时，好奇心本身在某种程度上就象征着有罪，对吧？换句话说，如果基本上我对纳粹为什么要做某事感到好奇，这几乎让我以某种方式变得可疑，因为你有点在说：“好吧，你为什么对试图弄清楚这个机制这么感兴趣？这难道不是显然是错的吗？”
Are you trying to find a justification for what happened? Exactly. That's exactly the psychology of this, that if you experience something with moral conviction, it feels ridiculous to ask, is this really wrong? Right? Of course, it's wrong. Two plus two equals four. Female circumcision is wrong.
你是在试图为发生的事情寻找辩护吗？完全正确。这正是这里的心理学，如果你带着道德信念去体验某事，去问“这真的是错的吗”会显得荒谬。对吧？当然它是错的。2加2等于4。女性割礼是错误的。
You don't need to probe this. And by very virtue of questioning it makes me worried about your character. Mm. And of course, I think to be clear, the point that you're making Linda, the reason you're interested in this is not because you think that female circumcision or genital mutilation is the right thing to do or an appropriate thing to do. You might still have reservations about it. You're interested in sort of the psychology of how people come to the conclusions they
你不需要探究这个。仅仅因为质疑它，就让我对你的品格感到担忧。嗯。当然，我认为需要明确的是，琳达，你提出的观点，你对这个感兴趣的原因并不是因为你认为女性割礼或生殖器切割是正确的事情或合适的事情。你可能对此仍然有所保留。你感兴趣的是人们如何得出他们所得到的结论的心理学。
come to. Exactly. And the most interesting things I think to study from a psychological perspective are the things that people really feel intensely about. And these people certainly feel intensely about this. What are your personal views right now on male and female circumcision? I'm far, no expert really on the topic, but I have read a considerable amount on it. And after reflecting on the arguments pros and cons, I really land on the issue of consent. It's not where I started, by the way, but it is where I've landed.
完全正确。从心理学的角度来看，我认为最有趣的研究对象是那些人们真正抱有强烈情感的事情。而这些人对这一点绝对抱有强烈的感情。你目前对男女割礼的个人看法是什么？我远算不上这个话题的专家，但我对此阅读了相当多的内容。在反思了正反两方面的论点后，我真正落脚点在于知情同意的问题。顺便说一句，这不是我的起点，但确实是我的落脚点。
That female and male circumcision are usually done on very young children, often without, well, never with their consent. And I think the issue that people are not given an opportunity to consent to intense body modification is ethically wrong? I'm wondering if one of the concerns about this area of research is the fear that in some ways when you study something scientifically and understand how it's put together psychologically, in some ways it diminishes the intensity
女性割礼和男性割礼通常是在非常小的孩子身上进行的，往往没有，嗯，从来没有得到他们的同意。我认为人们没有机会对剧烈的身体改造给予同意这一问题在伦理上是错误的？我想知道关于这一研究领域的担忧之一是否是这样一种恐惧：在某种程度上，当你对某事进行科学研究并在心理上理解它是如何组合的时，它在某种程度上减弱了强度
with which we feel about issues. It diminishes the strength of our positions. Perhaps even diminishes our convictions. If you actually know how the conviction comes together, if you understand the psychological mechanics of it, you understand, well, actually maybe this doesn't actually make that much sense, maybe it doesn't actually reflect my deepest values. And I'm wondering if this is one of the concerns that people might have about this body of research in general, which is it runs the risk of basically inviting more relativism, or basically saying everything is just a matter of your
会影响我们对问题的看法。这削弱了我们立场的坚定性。甚至可能削弱我们的信念。如果你真正了解这种信念是如何形成的，如果你理解其中的心理机制，你就会明白，实际上这可能并没有那么大意义，也许它并没有真正反映我最深层的价值观。我想知道，这是否是人们对这门整体研究的担忧之一，也就是它有可能招致更多的相对主义，或者基本上是认为一切都只是取决于你
personal view of what is right and what is wrong. Everything is negotiable, everything is up for grabs. There's nothing that's actually universally true. Yes, that is a decidedly a risk. But it's an empirical question to some degree, right? Is morality relative or is there an objective truth out there? And we don't really know unless we actually pry into the psychology of it. When we come back, what are the effects of our moral convictions in politics and on democracy. Compromise has become kind of a dirty word that their members of Congress, for example, compromise that is a failure of leadership and character. You're listening to Hidden Brain.
对什么是对、什么是错的个人看法。一切都可以商量，一切都可以争夺。没有什么东西是绝对普遍正确的。是的，这绝对是一种风险。但在某种程度上，这是一个经验性问题，对吧？道德是相对的，还是存在某种客观真理？如果我们不去深入探究其背后的心理学，我们其实无从得知。稍后回来，我们将探讨道德信念在政治和民主中会产生什么影响。妥协已经变成了一个有点贬义的词，例如，国会议员们的妥协，被认为是一种领导力和品格的失败。欢迎收听《隐藏的大脑》。
I'm Shankar Vedanta. Stay with us. At the University of Illinois at Chicago, psychologists Linda Skittka studies the nature and consequences of moral convictions. She finds these convictions both arise in the context of visceral emotions and arouse visceral emotions in us. When we are in the grip of such emotions, we are quite happy to disregard evidence, to discard the views of experts, and to question the legitimacy of institutions that don't agree with us. When you look out at the landscape of American politics, does any of this sound familiar? Linda also finds something even more disturbing. Moral convictions tend to prompt people to disregard the rules. You can see this on a large scale and you can measure it in laboratory experiments,
我是香卡·韦丹坦（Shankar Vedantam）。请继续收听。在伊利诺伊大学芝加哥分校，心理学家琳达·斯基特卡（Linda Skitka）专门研究道德信念的本质及其后果。她发现，这些信念既产生于内脏般的强烈情感之中，又会在我们体内激发出这种情感。当我们被这种情感支配时，我们会非常乐意无视证据、抛弃专家的观点，并质疑那些与我们意见不一致的机构的合法性。当你审视美国政治的现状时，这一切听起来是不是很熟悉？琳达还发现了一些更令人不安的事。道德信念往往会促使人们无视规则。你可以在宏观层面上看到这一点，也可以在实验室实验中对其进行测量，
such as this one by Janice Nadler and Elizabeth Mullin. This was a very ingenious study. They brought people into the study and they exposed them to a legal decision that was either consistent or inconsistent with people's moral convictions and gave them a pencil to complete the questionnaire about their reactions to it. And on known to the participants, they had some kind of electronic monitoring gizmo on it. They allowed them to find out whether the pencil was returned or not. And people were more likely to steal the pencil if they had to answer a questionnaire about a court decision that they morally disagreed with. And what seems to explain it the most is people's emotional reactions to decisions that they morally disagree with.
比如珍妮斯·纳德勒（Janice Nadler）和伊丽莎白·穆林（Elizabeth Mullin）进行的这项实验。这是一个非常巧妙的研究。他们把人们请进实验室，让他们接触一项法律判决，该判决要么符合、要么不符合人们的道德信念，然后给他们一支铅笔，让他们填写一份关于对此反应的问卷。在参与者不知情的情况下，铅笔上安装了某种电子监测装置。这让他们能够查明铅笔是否被归还。如果人们必须填写一份针对他们从道德上不认同的法院判决的问卷，他们就更有可能偷走这支铅笔。而最能解释这一现象的，似乎是人们对他们从道德上不认同的判决所产生的消极情绪反应。
That it makes people so angry that it cuts off their normal self-monitoring to behave according to the norms. So a few years ago, Linda, several of the parents of kids who were killed in the New Town School shooting began receiving abuse on the internet. People told them that they had fake the deaths of their children in order to push a gun control agenda. I want you to listen to this news clip. The families of the murdered children became the targets of conspiracy theorists who decided that the massacre did not happen. The children were not real or that the parents had been paid to stage the attack. And not only did they share these false and hateful messages among
这让人感到非常愤怒，以至于切断了他们按照规范行事的正常自我监控能力。因此，几年前，琳达，新镇校园枪击案中几名遇难儿童的父母开始在互联网上遭受虐待。人们告诉他们，他们伪造了自己孩子的死，以推动枪支管控议程。我想请大家听一段新闻剪辑。被害儿童的家属成了阴谋论者的目标，这些阴谋论者断定大屠杀根本没有发生。孩子们不是真的，或者说父母是被收买来假装发生袭击的。他们不仅在彼此之间分享这些虚假和充满仇恨的信息，
themselves, they began harassing families of the murdered children. I'm quite confident that the people who were doing this were acting out of a misplaced sense of moral conviction that killing of children is such a horrendous thing to contemplate. And when if that's inconsistent with something that you morally cherish, such as the right to bear weapons. You're going to have to do a whole bunch of psychological gymnastics in order to make the world make sense again. If you wanted here to this cherish, believe that guns are good,
还开始骚扰遇难儿童的家属。我深信，做出这种行为的人是出于一种错位的道德信念，即杀害儿童是一件多么令人发指的事情。而当这种信念与你从道德上珍视的某些东西（比如持枪权）不一致时。你将不得不进行一大堆心理体操，才能让这个世界重新变得合乎情理。如果你想坚持这种珍视的信念，即枪支是好的，
you're going to have to come up with an explanation for how something horrible could happen. And in some ways, this is connected to what we were talking earlier, of course, which is that when we are filled with moral certitude, we believe that the ends in some ways justify the means, right? Correct. We have several examples of that.
你就必须为如此可怕的事情是如何发生的给出一个解释。在某种程度上，这与我们刚才讨论的内容有关，当然，那就是当我们充满道德确定性时，我们相信在某种程度上目的可以证明手段的正当性，对吧？没错。我们有几个这方面的例子。
The vigilante example that we brought up earlier, but numerous others. If you want to think about any basic revolution that has occurred, most people who drum up the courage to engage in overthrowing their government, for example, must have a very strong moral conviction about the justice of the cause. At a less dramatic level, Linda and others have found that moral convictions make it very difficult to find common ground.
我们之前提到的私刑例子，还有无数其他例子。如果你想思考任何发生过的基本革命，大多数鼓起勇气参与推翻政府等活动的人，必须对这一事业的正义性抱有非常强烈的道德信念。在不太戏剧化的层面上，琳达和其他人发现，道德信念使得寻找共同点变得非常困难。
If you have a visceral response to female circumcision or female genital mutilation, for example, can you imagine sitting across from someone who believes the practice is fine, would you want to sit close to such a person? Researchers know the answer to that question because they've actually measured how people behave in such situations. Yes, there's been several studies that have put people competing more on convictions in the same room. Most of these have actually used chair placement as an indication of preferred physical distance away from people who disagree with us. And so in one study that we did on this topic, we brought participants into the study and we told them that we were going to
例如，如果你对女性割礼或女性生殖器切除术有着强烈的本能反应，你能想象和一个认为这种做法没问题的人坐在一起吗？你愿意挨这样的人坐近一点吗？研究人员知道这个问题的答案，因为他们实际上已经测量过人们在这种情况下的行为反应。是的，有几项研究把持有不同道德信念的人安排在同一个房间里。其中大多数研究实际上都使用椅子的摆放位置，来表示与不同意我们观点的人保持的偏好物理距离。因此，在我们关于这个主题的一项研究中，我们将参与者带入研究中，并告诉他们我们将
randomly assign half of them to learn something about who they were about to meet and half of them would not. And in every case, the participants learned that the person that they were about to meet and half of them would not. And in every case, the participants learned that the person that they were about to meet was very strongly pro-choice on the issue of abortion. We then escorted them into another room where they were supposed to actually meet this person. And what they saw when they walked into that room was a backpack on a chair.
随机指派其中一半人了解他们即将见面的人的一些情况，另一半人则不了解。在每一种情况下，参与者都了解到他们即将见面的人，另一半则没有。在每一种情况下，参与者都了解到他们即将见面的人在堕胎问题上非常强烈地支持堕胎选择权。然后我们把他们护送到另一个房间，他们本应在那里与这个人见面。当他们走进那个房间时，他们看到的是椅子上的一个背包。
And the backpack had a little button on it that was pro-choice, but there was no actual other research participant. And the experimenter would go, oh my, where's the other participant? They must have wandered off to try to find the bathroom or something. You know this building, they'll never find their way back. And the building we were in, in fact, is built on a principle of rotating squares and it's very complicated, so it was a very plausible cover story.
背包上有一个支持堕胎选择权的小徽章，但实际上并没有其他研究参与者。实验人员会说：“哦天哪，另一个参与者在哪？他们一定闲逛去找洗手间什么的了。你知道这栋楼，他们永远找不到回来的路。”事实上，我们所在的建筑是按旋转正方形的原则建造的，非常复杂，所以这是一个非常合理的掩护故事。
The experimenter would encourage the volunteer to grab a seat from a row of chairs against the wall. Then, she stepped out of the room to ostensibly go find the other person. In reality, there was no one else. The point of the experiment was merely to see where volunteers would place their chairs. And what we found is that people placed their chairs closer to people if they happen to share the attitude on abortion and put the chair further away if they disagreed with them. And the distance away was much bigger than the distance close. In other words, people preferred more distance to those they morally disagre disagree with than they prefer being closer to people they morally agreed with. One of the things that I find very interesting is the research that shows that this this
实验人员会鼓励志愿者从靠墙的一排椅子中随便找个座位坐下。然后，她走出了房间，借口去找另一个人。实际上，根本没有其他人。实验的重点仅仅是为了观察志愿者会把椅子放在哪里。我们发现，如果人们恰好在堕胎问题上有相同的态度，他们就会把椅子放得离对方更近；而如果意见不一致，就会把椅子放得更远。而且拉开的距离远大于靠近的距离。换句话说，与他们在道德上不一致的人相比，人们更倾向于与他们保持更大的距离，而不是更倾向于靠近他们在道德上一致的人。我发现非常有趣的一件事是，研究表明，这种
distance that we experience in physical space also translates into social space in all kinds of ways. We really want to keep our distance not just physically but socially from people whose moral views conflict with our own. Talk a little bit about the range of different social spaces that people have looked at where we actually want to keep our distance from people with different moral convictions. There's a whole range of social relationships we don't want to have with people who morally disagree with us. We don't want them to teach our children. We don't want them to be teach our children. We don't want them to marry into our family. We don't want them to move into our neighborhoods. We don't want them to be the owner of a store we might frequent.
我们在物理空间中体验到的距离，在各种方式上也转化为社会空间。我们真的希望不仅在身体上，而且在社会层面上与那些道德观点与我们冲突的人保持距离。请谈谈人们关注的不同社会空间范围，在这些空间中，我们实际上希望与持有不同道德信念的人保持距离。有一系列社会关系，我们不想与那些在道德上与我们意见不一致的人建立。我们不想让他们教导我们的孩子。我们不想让他们教导我们的孩子。我们不想让他们与我们的家族联姻。我们不想让他们搬进我们的社区。我们不想让他们成为我们可能经常光顾的商店的老板。
There are very few social roles, if any, that we want people who morally disagree with us to play in our lives. And why do you think that is? If one of my child's teachers has moral views that are different than mine, but the teacher is still a good teacher and my child likes the teacher and does well in class, what is it that I fear is going to happen by having that teacher teach my child? I think we're afraid that somehow this is going to rub off on the child, that they might be exposed to morally hateful views, whether that's true or not, we're worried about that carrying over. People disinselse from immoral things because they're worried that it might contaminate
在我们的生活中，几乎没有什么社会角色是愿意让那些在道德上与我们意见不一致的人来扮演的。你认为这是为什么呢？如果我孩子的某位老师的道德观点与我不同，但这位老师依然是个好老师，我孩子也喜欢这位老师并且在班上表现很好，那么让这位老师教导我的孩子，我到底害怕会发生什么呢？我想我们害怕这会以某种方式影响到孩子，害怕他们可能会接触到在道德上令人憎恶的观点，不管这是真是假，我们都很担心这种负面影响会蔓延开来。人们刻意与不道德的事物保持距离，是因为他们担心这可能会污染
them. That to even entertain having a conversation with someone who has a moral disagreement with you, for example, or who engages in immoral behavior, feels like you could catch it. And people are very resistant to getting contaminated with things that they consider to be immoral. Hmm. I want to pick up on this idea of contamination because it actually leads me to something else I was thinking about as I was reading your work. One of the things that happens in public debates that have to do with moral convictions is in fact this idea of contamination. So let's
他们。仿佛哪怕只是考虑与一个在道德上与你有分歧、或者从事不道德行为的人进行对话，都感觉像是会被传染一样。而且人们非常抵触被他们认为是不道德的事物所污染。嗯。我想接着谈谈这种“污染”的概念，因为这实际上让我联想到我在阅读你的著作时思考的另一件事。在与道德信念有关的公众辩论中发生的事情之一，实际上就是这种“污染”的概念。所以让我们
say, for example, I disagree with you about something and I disagree with you so strongly that I feel like you're an immoral person for believing what you believe because I believe so strongly in what I believe. Now let's say that someone else person see, you know, endorses your work in some way or is affiliated with your work in some way or is associated with you in some way, there's some part of my disdain for you that now rubs off on them. In other words, there's a guilt by association that follows that if I actually think that you're a bad person, someone who associates with you
假设，例如，我因为某件事不同意你的看法，并且我和你的分歧如此之烈，以至于我觉得因为你坚信你所相信的东西，你就是一个不道德的人。现在假设另一个人——C先生，你知道的——以某种方式赞同你的作品，或者以某种方式与你的作品有关联，或者以某种方式与你联系在一起，我对你的蔑视现在有一部分就传染到了他们身上。换句话说，存在一种随之而来的“因关联而产生的罪恶感”，如果我真的认为你是一个坏人，那么与你交往的人
should also be a bad person. I mean, the extreme example of this is, if you think about the Nazis, would you like someone who was friends with the Nazi, who wasn't actually a Nazi himself, but was just friends with the Nazi, and the answer would quite obviously be no. There's a long line of research evidence that indicates exactly that, although this is
也应该是个坏人。我的意思是，极端的例子就是，如果你想到纳粹，你会喜欢一个和纳粹是朋友的人吗？他自己其实不是纳粹，而只是纳粹的朋友，答案显然是不会。有一系列长期的研究证据正好表明了这一点，尽管这
probably true of things that are both morally loaded and not morally loaded, that if you intensely dislike someone and that other person likes someone, people will intensely dislike that third person as well. This has been studied in a form of balance theory that people like to keep a psychological balance that bad things are bad things and good things are good things and things that associate with bad things are bad and things that associate with good things are good. So you know you can make compromises where you feel that others have different views of perspectives.
可能既适用于带有道德色彩的事物，也适用于不带道德色彩的事物：如果你强烈不喜欢某个人，而另一个人又喜欢那个人，人们也会强烈不喜欢那个第三者。这已经在平衡理论的形式中得到了研究，人们喜欢维持一种心理平衡，即坏事就是坏事，好事就是好事，与坏事相关联的东西是坏的，与好事相关联的东西是好的。所以你知道，当觉得别人有不同的观点或视角时，你可以做出妥协。
You say tomato, I say tomato, but compromise on moral convictions feels entirely different. It feels immoral to say I'm going to compromise on my moral principles. We really think that attitudes come in at least three different flavors. That some attitudes are experienced as preferences. That for example, I might really like chocolate, but you prefer vanilla. That's okay. We understand that some attitudes were in that domain and you know, whatever floats your boat, right? Or don't yuck on my yum.
你说是番茄（tomato），我说是番茄（tomahto），但对道德信念的妥协感觉完全不同。说我要在道德原则上妥协，这感觉是不道德的。我们真的认为态度至少有三种不同的风味。有些态度被体验为偏好。例如，我可能真的很喜欢巧克力，但你更喜欢香草。没关系。我们理解有些态度属于这个领域，你知道，各有所好嘛，对吧？或者别对我的喜好评头论足。
And the whole host of attitudes fall into that kind of domain where we're very, very tolerant. Other kinds of attitudes we experience more as normative or convention. For example, the right way to drive in the United States is to drive on the right-hand side of the street, but we understand that that's a coordination role. This is just how everybody does it. It's perfectly fine if people in other countries like the UK or Australia drive on the left-hand side of the street. Aditys in this domain are what people in my group believe or use to coordinate our behavior.
大量态度都属于这种领域，对此我们非常非常宽容。其他种类的态度，我们更多地将其体验为规范或惯例。例如，在美国正确的驾驶方式是在街道的右侧行驶，但我们明白这是一种协调规则。这只是大家做事的方式。如果其他国家（如英国或澳大利亚）的人在左侧行驶，那是完全没问题的。这一领域的态度就是我群体中的人所相信的，或者用来协调我们行为的东西。
Some religious belief is in this domain. For example, in some religious communities, certain foods are prohibited. It's okay if other religious groups don't prohibit those foods. We understand that that's a scot of narrow boundary on it. More all convictions, on the other hand, are things that we perceive as universally and objectively true on the transcend group boundaries. They're very intolerant and very close to compromise. In addition to having stronger ties with emotion, then attitudes that are experienced as
某些宗教信仰就属于这个领域。例如，在某些宗教社群中，某些食物是被禁止的。如果其他宗教群体不禁止这些食物，那是可以的。我们理解这有其狭隘的界限。另一方面，道德信念是我们认为普遍且客观真实、超越群体界限的东西。它们非常不宽容，而且极难妥协。除了与情感的联系比被体验为
preferences or conventions. So when people have strong moral convictions, you and others have found that the strength of these convictions predict that they will find a very difficult to develop procedures to resolve differences. Talk about this work that you've done about the challenges that moral convictions pose when it comes to actually finding compromise with others.
偏好或惯例的态度更强之外，当人们拥有强烈的道德信念时，你和其他人发现，这些信念的强度预示着他们会发现发展解决分歧的程序非常困难。请谈谈你所做的关于道德信念在实际寻找与他人妥协时带来挑战的研究。
We have done some really interesting research in this area. For example, in one study we brought four people into our lab to have conversations. And they were directed to have conversations not about how to determine the outcome of something or what the outcome should be. For example, whether capital punishment should be banned or allowed. Instead, they were supposed to come to consensus about the procedures we should use to decide whether capital punishment should be banned or allowed. And the groups that came in were either added to have strong moral convictions about the issue as well. So again, here's a setup. Volunteers with similar and different views on a subject were asked to come up with a set of procedures to arrive at a consensus.
我们在这一领域做了一些非常有趣的研究。例如，在其中一项研究中，我们将四个人带到我们的实验室进行对话。他们被指示进行的对话不是关于如何决定某个结果或结果应该是什么，例如死刑是应该被禁止还是被允许。相反，他们应该就我们用来决定是否应该禁止或允许死刑的程序达成共识。参与进来的群体要么也被要求对该问题抱有强烈的道德信念。所以再次说明，这是一个设定。志愿者们对某个主题有相似或不同的观点，被要求提出一套达成共识的程序。
The goal wasn't to arrive at a consensus, just to set up the rules to get there. What Linda and her colleagues wanted to know is whether having moral convictions helped or hindered people as they tried to figure out how to work with one another. The researchers found that when people merely disagreed coming up with ground rules for the conversation was easy, but when they had strong moral convictions, arriving at even the basic ground rules was difficult. It was very tense. Third-party judges viewed videotapes of these conversations and rated them as more tense and defensive. And they had much greater difficulty coming up with a compromise solution to decide the issue. Interestingly enough, if the groups were high on moral conviction and all had the same opinion,
目标不是达成共识，而只是建立达成共识的规则。琳达和她的同事们想要了解的是，拥有道德信念在人们试图弄清楚如何合作时是起到了帮助还是阻碍作用。研究人员发现，当人们仅仅存在分歧时，为对话制定基本规则很容易；但当他们拥有强烈的道德信念时，连达成最基本的地方法规都变得很困难。当时的气氛非常紧张。第三方裁判观看了这些对话的录像，并评价其更加紧张和充满防御性。他们在提出妥协方案来解决问题时遇到了更大的困难。有趣的是，如果这些群体具有高度的道德信念且持有完全相同的意见，
they also had a problem coming up with a procedure to resolve the issue. The morally convicted groups just couldn't come up with a procedure that they were confident enough would achieve the right outcome. And so therefore couldn't come to consensus about what that procedure might be. When you look at polarization in politics today, how much of it would you attribute to the growing number of issues in which Americans have strong moral convictions?
他们在提出解决问题的程序时也会遇到问题。抱有道德信念的群体就是无法提出一个他们有足够信心能够取得正确结果的程序。因此，他们无法就该程序可能是什么达成共识。当你审视当今政治中的极化现象时，你会将其归咎于美国人拥有强烈道德信念的议题数量不断增加，这占了多大比例？
A decent amount. Compromises become kind of a dirty word in politics. That constituencies think their members of Congress, for example, compromise that is a failure of leadership and character. So yes, I do think that people feeling moral convictions about many of the key issues of the day is leading to challenges in achieving policy solutions that everybody can live with. So there's a profound paradox here in the story, Linda, as a country, the United States was
相当大的比例。妥协在政治中已经变成了一个贬义词。选民们认为他们的国会议员等人的妥协是领导力和品格的失败。所以是的，我确实认为人们对当今许多核心议题抱有道德信念，导致了在达成所有人都能接受的政策解决方案时面临挑战。因此，这个故事中存在一个深刻的悖论，琳达，作为一个国家，美国是
founded on moral principles. You know, set aside for a moment whether the country has always lived up to those principles, but when you read the Declaration of Independence, we hold these truths to be self-evident that all men are created equal. We are hearing moral conviction. It's self-evident, it needs no proof, it's categorical, it brooks no doubt. In other words, we are a country in some ways that's founded on moral conviction, but we're also a country in some ways that's foundering as a result of very strong moral convictions. How do you think about that, not just as a researcher but as a citizen in terms of your work,
建立在道德原则之上的。你知道，先抛开这个国家是否一直践行这些原则不谈，但当你阅读《独立宣言》时，“我们认为这些真理是不言而喻的：人人生而平等。”我们在这里听到了道德信念。它是自明的不证自明的，不需要证明，它是绝对的，不容置疑的。换句话说，我们在某种程度上是一个建立在道德信念之上的国家，但我们在某种程度上也是一个因极强的道德信念而正在瓦解的国家。你是如何看待这一点的，不仅作为一名研究人员，而且作为一名公民，就你的工作而言，
how do you unpack that irony, Linda? I get asked this a great deal at the time, and that is our moral convictions good or bad things. I would have to say I don't think I want to live in a world without moral convictions, good or bad things. I would have to say, I don't think I want to live in a world without moral convictions, even if sometimes they lead to things that would seem to be pretty negative. Largely because without moral convictions, I don't think you would have any desire to ever change anything.
你如何解开这个反讽，琳达？我经常被问到这个问题，那就是我们的道德信念到底是好东西还是坏东西。我不得不说，我认为我不想生活在一个没有道德信念的世界里，无论它们是好是坏。我不得不说，我不想生活在一个没有道德信念的世界里，即使有时它们会导致看起来相当消极的事情。主要是因为如果没有道德信念，我想你不会有任何想要改变现状的愿望。
Or to fight for more just society. Or to fight for very much at all. And so if we ever hope to improve our lot, I think we need morally convicted others that are willing to become politically engaged, willing to volunteer, willing to fight for those causes in order to achieve anything better than what we currently have. How do you, how do you square the circle though? Because we've been discussing essentially this irony, which is, you know, I, I like you would not want to live in a world where people did not have
或者为更公正的社会而战。或者为任何事情去抗争。因此，如果我们希望改善我们的命运，我认为我们需要那些愿意积极参与政治、愿意当志愿者、愿意为这些事业而战的具有道德信念的人，以便取得比我们目前所拥有的更好的成果。不过，你如何圆这个方呢？因为我们一直在讨论本质上是这种反讽的东西，你知道，我和你一样，不愿意生活在一个人们没有
strong moral convictions. At the same time, I can see how, you know, when tens of millions of people have very strong moral convictions about dozens of issues, it can bring compromise to a halt and ultimately be self-defeating. Do you see your work sort of reflected in the world around you when you watch the news? Well, it's certainly in the news all the time right now because we are in a very polarized place in the United States and I think people are drawing lots of moral dividing lines. But on the other hand you also can see lots of people are really motivated to make the world better. The response recently to police violence for example, although complicated, nonetheless
强烈道德信念的世界里。与此同时，我能看出，当数千万人在几十个问题上拥有非常强烈的道德信念时，它是如何让妥协陷入停顿并最终适得其反的。当你观看新闻时，你是否看到你的工作在周围的世界中得到某种反映？嗯，它现在肯定一直都在新闻里，因为我们正处于美国高度极化的时期，我认为人们正在划定许多道德分水岭。但另一方面，你也能看到很多人确实有动力让世界变得更好。例如，最近对警察暴力的反应虽然很复杂，但尽管如此，
has spurred people even in the context of the pandemic to shout for justice. It's interesting even given the cost of the pandemic it's very high to go out and make your voice heard at this moment. Many people know people nonetheless are. I can't talk to your parents. I can't talk to your grandparents. At some point you got to be the boy for the black people in your household and that's the start today. And with nine minutes, that officer, that is me on George Neck. You think they can. I mean I think what I find really interesting about your work is that looking at it from a psychological perspective allows us to get beyond the questions of, you know, our moral convictions good or our moral convictions bad, because in some ways, the same things that make them good are also potentially what make them bad, right?
它仍然激发了人们（甚至在疫情大流行期间）为正义呐喊。有趣的是，即使大流行病的代价非常高昂，人们在这个时刻仍然走出去让自己的声音被听到。很多人认识人，但人们依然这么做了。我不能跟你父母谈。我不能跟你祖父母谈。在某个时刻，你必须成为你家里黑人的代言人，而今天就是开始。在经历了9分钟之后，那个警官，那个人就是我身上的乔治·纳克。你认为他们能。我的意思是，我认为你的研究真正有趣的地方在于，从心理学的角度来看，它让我们超越了“我们的道德信念是好是坏”的问题，因为在某些方面，
In other words, the fact that people are willing to disregard the rules, disregard norms, fight against injustice, change systems, you know, potentially think that the end-justify the means are all the reasons that good things happen as a result of moral convictions. They're also a reason why bad things happen as a result of moral convictions. What's interesting is psychologically the things driving both these things sound like they might be the same phenomena. Exactly. They're sides of a double-edged sword. Blindly following authority in the rules isn't always a normatively good thing.
使它们成为好东西的因素，也同样有可能使它们成为坏东西，对吧？换句话说，人们愿意无视规则、无视规范、反抗不公、改变体制、潜在地认为目的正当可以证明手段正当，这些都是道德信念带来美好结果的所有原因。它们也是道德信念带来坏结果的原因。有趣的是，从心理学上讲，驱动这两者的东西听起来可能完全是同一现象。完全正确。它们是一把双刃剑的两个面。盲目服从权威和规则并不总是一件规范上好的事情。
And if we over-conditioned people to be completely obedient, blindly obedient, destructive things can happen as well. So in those cases, we want people who have the moral conviction that can allow them to resist that kind of mellow and authority. On the other hand, it's hard to imagine a civil society functioning very long if we don't have some coordination roles and basic obedience to common norms of conduct. I mean, I'm wondering when you, when you look at your research and you look at the world, what happens if you have an election and at the end of the election, your side doesn't win and you believe your side really ought to win, not just that they ought to win because they were better politically but because they're better morally.
如果我们过度训练人们变得完全顺从、盲目顺从，也会发生破坏性的事情。因此，在这种情况下，我们需要那些拥有道德信念的人，这些信念能让他们抵制那种对权威的盲从。另一方面，如果我们没有一些协调规则和对共同行为规范的基本服从，就很难想象一个公民社会能够长期运作。我的意思是，我想知道，当你审视自己的研究并审视这个世界时，如果你经历了一场选举，而选举结束时你支持的一方没有赢，而你认为你的一方真的应该赢，不仅仅是因为他们在政治上更好，而是因为他们在道德上更好，
Do you think that might prompt me to support taking extra constitutional steps to keep power because my commitment is now to my cause? It's not really to the rules of my country. I think there's a risk of that. If there were enough people with that strong and moral conviction, but one hopes that maybe an overriding moral conviction is a belief in the fairness of our democratic processes and election procedures. And this is where I think arguing that our election procedures could be flawed is a particularly dangerous thing to do. We need basic commitment or belief in the idea that our electoral processes are higher
你认为这会不会促使我支持采取超越宪法的步骤来保持权力，因为我的承诺现在是对我的事业？它实际上并不是对我的国家规则的承诺。我认为存在这种风险。如果有很多具有这种强烈道德信念的人，但人们希望也许一种凌驾一切的道德信念是对我们民主程序和选举程序公平性的信仰。而正是在这一点上，我认为争论我们的选举程序可能有缺陷是一件特别危险的事情。我们需要对这样一种理念做出基本的承诺或信仰，即我们的选举程序是更高
order, more good, that allows us to subsume our individual commitments to individual candidates. I, like many other people, are deeply interested in politics and have my own political points of view and certainly some of those rise to level moral conviction. However, I do think I can temper it by thinking them through in terms of what am I really committed to and I think an overriding moral commitment and I'm Psychologist Linda Skitka works at the University of Illinois at Chicago. Linda, thank you for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Thank you. We're willing to be beaten for democracy, and you must use democracy in the street.
层次的、更好的，这允许我们服从于对个别候选人的个人承诺。我和许多其他人一样，对政治有着深厚的兴趣，有自己的政治观点，当然其中一些上升到了道德信念的水平。然而，我确实认为我可以通过根据“我真正承诺的是什么”来进行思考来缓和它，我认为这是一种凌驾一切的道德承诺，而且我是……心理学家琳达·斯基特卡在伊利诺伊大学芝加哥分校工作。琳达，谢谢你今天做客《隐藏的大脑》。谢谢。我们愿意为民主挨打，你必须在街头运用民主。
It is wrong, deadly wrong, to deny any of your fellow Americans, the right to vote in this country. Let's go ahead! Go home! Roar me way! Let's go ahead! Go home! Roar me way!
剥夺任何同胞美国人在这个国家的投票权是错误的，大错特错。我们走吧！回家！大声喊出来！我们走吧！回家！大声喊出来！
Look, slide! Show me what the vaccine looks like! This is what the vaccine looks like! Show me what it looks like! Well, we're going to out-organize, outlast, and out-hype all the other corners. We are seeing those huge lines. A lot of people want to get out and vote early.
看，滑动！让我看看疫苗长什么样！这就是疫苗的样子！让我看看它长什么样！嗯，我们要通过组织、持久战和声势压倒所有其他角落。我们看到了那些长龙。很多人都想早点出去投票。
I mean, we're not even going to try to walk through this crowd anymore. Like we were earlier this morning. You could see they are now piling in as the lines just opened up. I feel very strongly about this election. And I could now wait to cast my vote another minute. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Midrall Media is our exclusive advertising sales partner. Our audio production team includes Brigitte McCarthy, Laura Correll, Autumn Barnes and Andrew Chadwick.
我的意思是，我们甚至不再试图走过这群人了。就像我们今天早些时候那样。你可以看到，随着队伍刚刚开放，他们现在正蜂拥而入。我对这次选举有着强烈的感受。我再也等不急哪怕一分钟去投下我的一票了。《隐藏的大脑》由 Hidden Brain 媒体制作。Midrall 媒体是我们独家广告销售合作伙伴。我们的音频制作团队包括布里吉特·麦卡锡（Brigitte McCarthy）、劳拉·科雷尔（Laura Correll）、奥特姆·巴恩斯（Autumn Barnes）和安德鲁·查德威克（Andrew Chadwick）。
Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. Special thanks this week to our former producers Thomas Liu and Kat Shuknecht. Our run song hero today is Kerry Darkonte. She's a senior manager of partnerships at Stitcher, our new distribution partner. Kerry has skillfully guided us through the transition, coming up with solutions to every challenge imaginable. She's always helpful, always kind. If this whole podcasting thing doesn't work out,
塔拉·博伊尔（Tara Boyle）是我们的执行制片人。我是《隐藏的大脑》执行主编。本周特别鸣谢我们的前制片人托马斯·刘（Thomas Liu）和卡特·舒克涅赫特（Kat Shuknecht）。我们今天的无名英雄是凯莉·达孔特（Kerry Darkonte）。她是我们的新发行伙伴 Stitcher 的高级合作伙伴经理。凯莉熟练地指导我们度过了这次过渡，为每一个可以想象到的挑战提出了解决方案。她总是乐于助人，总是那么善良。如果整个播客的事情行不通，
you might consider a future career as a psychotherapist or president. For more Hidden Brain, you can follow us on Facebook and Twitter. Find more information about us at hiddenbrain.org. If you like this episode and like our show, please remember to tell one friend about it. Next week on the show, we conclude our series on counterintuitive ways of seeing the world in 2020. We look at the political divide in America,
你或许可以考虑把心理治疗师或总统作为未来的职业。有关《隐藏的大脑》的更多信息，您可以在 Facebook 和 Twitter 上关注我们。请在 hiddenbrain.org 上查找关于我们的更多信息。如果你喜欢这一集并喜欢我们的节目，请记得向一位朋友推荐它。下周的节目中，我们将结束关于 2020 年看待世界反直觉方式的系列节目。我们将探讨美国的政治分歧，
and here's a hint. It's not the one we're always talking about. What people were concerned about is essentially politics coming up in their day-to-day lives. They actually were not as concerned about the opposing partisanship component of it. See you next week. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这里有个提示。这不是我们经常谈论的那一个。人们关心的是基本上在其日常生活中出现的政治。他们实际上并不那么关心与之相关的反对党派成分。下周见。这一集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。